okay
no mysterious appearances of a sudden
man hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome back to the
shadow of rose
I need to get the hell out of here
because I got kidnapped after I just got
the Third Mask which means
that I might be getting close to the end
of this DLC which would be so sad
because I'm having a good time with this
but I don't know I imagine there's gonna
be
another bit of a surprise once this all
gets sorted out
I'm just thirsting for more of this
sweet delectable content that I couldn't
stand the idea of being away from this
beautiful mansion I remember this area
rusted scrap is there anything else that
I can build lots of stuff I could build
do I want to build it not yet I don't
actually I'm Gonna Save I know I just
admonished you guys for doing the thing
where you don't spend your resources
that you have but I just
I don't know maybe there's a hard mode
for this because I haven't seen enough
uh that actually requires me to spend my
resources
I'm saving it for the final boss then I
will use anything oh and everything you
have my promise about that yeah
[Music]
mem money
what do you want it about yeah this is
where Ethan first came into the manner I
do believe
or maybe not was it
I can't remember but this is definitely
the kitchen area
uh-huh oh I have all three masks so I
guess I just go place them don't I
there's really nothing else to do right
hello
oh almost time
oh I'm sure this will be immediately
over what is on the oh
what was that
what do you really want to have to admit
kind of weird
to let them go
hmm I know
I know
it also is very strange that there's
just this purifying crystal inside of a
mutomy seat memory that can get rid of
this thing why would the crystal to get
rid of the mutant my seat be inside the
neurons of the mute to my seat
or the sclerosure
or whatever one more
oh well nothing else to do about it blap
I did it I'm the best
okay
I guess I just grabbed it
whenever there's a cutscene that turns
my back on the majority of the room
things always go good for me
well done little one
you've more than earned this reward
almost looks like the real thing doesn't
you no
I knew it
I knew it it's a replica of course
nothing that valuable could ever
manifest on this stratum I was pretty
sure about that
don't do that did you really think I'd
give away something so precious
maybe I had to bait the trap with
something
nope
[Laughter]
that's kind of mean man you were nicer
before I know you can't remember
anything but why'd you have to default
in douchebag mode
[Music]
thanks I was before do I have to guess
which sclerosis
[Laughter]
now comes the real fun man you love
laughing perfect place for your demise
you know something about being evil just
makes people really want to laugh and I
don't know what that's about oh
oh wait wait hold on this is exactly
where I knew that I was gonna need all
this stuff
okay I'm out of gunpowder that
probably should thought about that a bit
more but I'm gonna use my shout gun
missed everything
holy crap what is that
come here reload oh I should have
reloaded before Oh God come on oh
okay hold still buddy
nice okay this is going well what do I
have do I have any more of those yes
oh God don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't
that is going swimmingly
oh God no no no no no no no no no
okay so far so good
oh do it did I do it probably not
too much spice yeah
oh boy
okay do oh pipe bomb
why why
oh God
oh God no oh oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait don't suck my face I
don't need any of that I don't need any
of that I don't need that I don't need
that this is oh no you got me in oh no
no oh uh thank you that guy saved me I
think he hammered them away holy crap
they saved me
oh
I'm just oh well that's a lot of
thumping behind whoa
there is glutes don't mind me wait oh
wow this is a lot of pausing okay ow
okay hold on hold on oh okay hold on I
don't know why I need to do this here
and now let me just
I can take one more hit
oh
oh it's just let me Goose let me Goose
my dude
foreign
that's not good
where'd you go where'd you go where are
you oh he's fast
oh
holy crap
why did I do that why did I just get a
loop-de-loop
oh oh you real you suck a lot oh man you
really suck
okay that's Bluestem
I guess it was just so I could keep
running away from him all right you have
something on your back that I okay no
you were just taking a breather and
that's totally fine and that's not
unfair at all
right I've ever seen what do you mean
insipid I'm doing great
I'm doing so good I'm gonna try to pipe
on them where are you you call this a
show I don't actually
I'll pipe on them
perfect nice
well bombed don't let her get away with
that
oh what is this take this
well this is awfully convenient do I
have time to concentrate on this oh I
see
okay you you
stop you hold still hold still
okay and then
bye bomb I see it in the back
oh boy oh boy
what are you oh interesting where you
going buddy
[Music]
oh good stop being you
just stop it
[Applause]
no no no no no more dilly dally that's
what I always say
I love Dilly
and Dally
oh boy oh no not good
oh
useless creature
a disappointment
and that's why you save all your goodies
for the final battle no matter
you're imminent demise
inevitable
imminent and inevitable I don't think so
also why do you have so much control
over all this stuff why don't I have
control
all right okay all right I hear you loud
and clear
here okay
are you lying clear okay
well okay I guess I don't actually
it's not so much me
I did it everybody
I did it I'm very proud of myself
laughs
[Music]
where am I now
I knew that that couldn't have been it
if it was only about finding those three
masks
a deeper stratum deeper you go harder to
escape
oh good if it was only about those masks
then it wouldn't have been anything
right I didn't want to leave the DLC
would have been so incredibly short
it might revisit freak I want to have
friends I want to live a normal life
without this
curse hmm
that purifying Crystal can make that
happen make me normal
and I'm not going back until I find it
hmm
stubborn yeah so
searching okay this must be her dad like
the spirit of her dad in this kind of
with one with the mute to my seat or
someone like that
I can't imagine it's Lady D being
generous but what I was saying is like I
knew that there had to be more because
it would have been just too short and I
wonder if it's going to go through like
all the different locations of the
original game I know where the crystal
is I don't care I don't trust you
don't trust you at all
that's a different map look than it was
before do I still have my weapons I do
ah
good great
oh boy
will you be my friend
listen I got a I have a lot of friends
more than I can keep up with right now I
do need more friends I uh you seem to
have a great personality whoever you are
mysterious Force
but uh
my friends list is all full up you know
let's play yes
that is what this is yes
I swear I've seen these monkeys before
but
what the hell
yep nothing like a good old let's play
that's what we're all about
here
oh
um
interesting I remember where this went
before
that means I'm gonna hold on to it for a
little bit but let's see if it goes
where I'm thinking what what's wrong
it blocked me okay oh
what
something seems different looks yes
something oh these Wood Walls I don't
remember this being
fascinating there was one moment in
Resident Evil 8 or Village
okay this is weird that was Far Far
scarier than all the other moments in
the game and that took place in this
house looks rusted shut
examine
like a breaker box for the elevator but
it's locked tight so I'm guessing I
can't use it welcome Rose good
oh boy
January 5th today was my first day of
school I've always wanted to go I'm
gonna give Chris a big hug next time I
see him there were so many kids my age
it was like I walked into a TV show or
something I was so scared when I had to
introduce myself to the class but I was
still super duper excited to be there
I'm gonna make so many friends I'm gonna
try to talk to them tomorrow
I tried to be brave and talk to some
other kids but no one wants to talk to
me school work is super easy it's all
stuff I learned with Mommy but I guess I
shouldn't answer all the teachers
questions the boy behind me said
something really mean my hands go icky
with white sweat when I panic it was
really bad today today the teacher
yelled at me for always carrying a hanky
she says I'm not a baby anymore the boys
at school keep saying I'm icky but I
take a bath every night always wear
clean clothes and bring a fresh hanky
every day it's because of the stupid
white sweat whenever it starts coming
out of my hands I wipe it off right away
but sometimes I won't wipe off so I just
hold my hanky real tight Chris even told
the teacher it can't get anyone sick but
it doesn't change anything
finally talked to me Lucy from my class
said she always wanted to be friends
we're going to have lunch tomorrow I
can't believe it I'm so happy I hope
Lucy's friend Catherine will be my
friend too
it's your Journal ain't it don't you
hate it when white Sweat Just oozes from
your pores
that does sound a little strange but I
wouldn't bully I'm not a bully I ain't
no I'm not a bully no way
no way I'm not a bully that is
unfortunate though
and I would be very very sad for you
Rose if it weren't for the fact that you
have basically superpowers is there a
picture of me
interesting looks like photoshop's oil
paint filter
but also
drippy flowers
if I wasn't in the middle of what is
probably going to be a jump scare
hallway
oh yeah
[Music]
okay all right let's evaluate this it
appears that there's a purifying crystal
in the middle of that room
purifying crystal is the objective of
Rose's mission
it's probably not that easy but oh well
whatever hey look at this
not even gonna check the corners the
crystal right there but there's no way
to get it
oh God
[Music]
my stuff
oh God why oh what's wrong with you
what's inside of you oh what's inside a
gun is there a gun in you the stomach
has been stitched up it looks like
there's something inside I think my
gun's inside
Mr Monkey has a tummy ache he might give
you the crystal if you help him
oh boy
I am so glad though that they brought
this part back because
it was my favorite well not my favorite
of the whole village there were many
things to like about Village one of
these days I'll play it all again
but
I'm sorry
you squeaky Squinkie hello who's
dripping who's dripping who's dripping
no one's dripping that's impossible
there's ah a faucet
all right there's something I forgot in
here let's go in here before I forget
with the squeaks it's awfully squeaky
extremely squeaky actually hello
yeah that's for the best
all right just gonna go down this
ominous hallway around this blind Corner
whoa Jimmy's room
can't go in there I'm not allowed I
never asked for permission okay all
right so it's probably nothing's gonna
jump out of me until it's time to jump
out
it's going to happen
which is going to happen happened at
very prescribed
Junctions
uh scribbles
uh scribbles
scribbles
like from the other side scribbles
[Music]
that's fine
what
someone's sharpening a knife
uh-huh okay
so that's what I need to do the stuffed
Locker the picture on the bookshelf the
desk covered in stuff
okay so there were secret things to find
in there the stuffed Locker the picture
on the bookshelf the desk covered in
stuff okay stuffed Locker picture on the
bookshelf desk covered in stuff
got it
stuff Locker
picture on the bookshelf okay picture on
the bookshelf
uh
44. I have something to write with so
stuffed blocker picture on the bookshelf
desk covered in stuff so this is the
middle two numbers I'm not going to
question the blood also I don't know
what a stuffed bookshelf is
sure what that is supposed to be
yes covered in stuff there's a desk
covered in stuff here
it's more covered in stuff than the oh
99 stuff
Ed
bookshelf
uh that's not what I would call stuffed
either of these but it could be
ah it is stuffed
foreign
you know what that's for the best I
didn't need to go in there anyway I
didn't want to go in there I didn't want
anything to do with in there in there
was actually not where I need to be or
Ever After the thing anyway oh right the
code the lady goes right over here
is that not a picture on the bookshelf
discover that I mean this is
what I got that's it
unless it's oh why did I read that as 99
my brain just flipped that upside down
for some reason
oh I could have gone the other way
listen I can hear a lot of you judging
me out there
it's not how it is it's not what it's
all about
oh boy excuses
I like excusers nothing what's gonna
happen now
oh
good the hands are here what the hell
high five baby yeah put him up wham wham
wham wham was that a shadow I saw anyway
congratulations
I'm back baby baby I'm back I'm on a
roll I'm back baby
no time like the present
you don't mind this do you this is I've
done this before once
snip
baby
[Laughter]
there seems to be an infection
oh
no what do you mean what are you talking
about what are you referring to Ken what
now
hmm okay Lucy
uh Lucy
can't use that there no label okay
maybe you'll get the crystal once you
get the campfire started oh I don't know
move I should I don't know if I should
all right oh what's all this then
I bet you can find all kinds of places
to play with this doll and her friends
well I didn't get a doll yet oh there we
go doll pose one
okay well Lucy
um
is there anything difference it was
completely illegible all right doll pose
one
Lucy
what are you doing Lucy Lucy what are
you doing
man I would be bad in a survival
situation if I needed to be quiet I
can't go back out I bet oh I can
shockingly okay so I got the relief of
the child
yeah
pretty much hey
just not glasses or something like that
I ain't no nerd all right so relief love
child
foreign
boy that child's relieved
I'll post too
no one wants to be your friend what a
loser
feel like that kind of
foreign
[Laughter]
I can I don't know if it's going to be
useful okay so doll pose two was right
there but I don't know if I gotta bring
the dolls back over here to when I get
three and then maybe three will turn to
four
okay I still can't go through there
because that's rusted
um
I have two dolls one of which was over
there oh my gosh through you
hey my painting
you mannequin you mannequin getting me
you you you doing the mannequins to me
huh I remember the mannequins I am well
immured
I'm not using that word right on the
mirrored to your scares
Alexian put up the definite mission of
immured e-m-u-r-e-d
- and show how I'm not using it right
okay so there's three spots here four
technically I guess it might be that I
need to use three over there because
there are four spots here
willing to bet that that that's actually
kind of close to what it is
yeah that is what it is okay
Lucy got it Lucy
uh-huh this seems mean
seems mean
[Music]
yeah yeah I get it [ __ ] you
that is the appropriate response to this
Jimmy's room give give
we need to clean that gross mold off of
her uh
I get it that is the right attitude
though so good on you Rose I'm not
afraid of you guys I'm not afraid of
anything here
you think you can scare me
no
oh boy where's Jimmy's room got to be in
the basement
Jimmy why you got me in the basement
Jimmy
oh yeah take this
I don't know if the same kind of applies
down here or what I don't want to go
down there just yet
[Laughter]
I don't get what's so funny but then
again I'm not very humorous I'm going
down
good
great actually
the best oh that's convenient
thank you
this is so creepy oh come on this is
creepy it's just the bottom of a well
you're the scary one because in the ring
it was a a little girl crawling out of
well and killing people you're that
you're the girl doesn't really do well
for the whole bullying thing
what do you think you're I don't think
yeah no way yeah get out of here go
screw yourself go away I hate you
okay good good good good good good good
good good
stuff good good great this is good this
is all very good this is great good oh
more
good
hey
what was that sound
what was that what what was them
what do I sound I'm sure this all tells
a very lovely story if I were to stop
and look at it all but I'd I'll let the
lore Masters look into that I got I got
some dolls to place so if I recall
doll 2 was there so that must be where
doll to go it's not really it looks like
it might say Lucy though
uh sure I do Jimmy Jimmy sure
is that right probably not right
let's put Jimmy there that might be
Jimmy as well
that makes sense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is where you say something sassy in your
life yeah right okay anyway I'm gonna go
save I like saving
foreign
no mysterious appearances of a sudden
man
be gone demon your different sized pupil
is indicative that you are suffering
from a stroke
[Music]
terrible ass okay we're just not gonna
talk about any of that that would be
lovely it would be lovely okay so who uh
okay so judging by that looks like the
Jimmy and he's holding a bundle of
sticks and you
go there question mark yeah that makes
sense okay that all checks out so they
all generally have a similar pose and
then
it's clearly more cheaply made than the
other dolls I can't tell that how can
you tell that
seriously
[Music]
[ __ ] you
it is a little immature
so sad
am I oh
hello
[Music]
yeah fine I'll help you out just take
the elevator to me
mommy might be upset that I'm helping
you though
[Music]
who are you
yeah who are you I don't recognize
I don't really recognize the voice from
the other the base game I'm not exactly
sure who this is
but seems to be okay
let's play statue I don't want to play
Statues what do you mean what do you
mean like weeping angel statues that's
the only that's the only game of statues
that I know
don't
do it
whatever you do
don't do it
whatever you're thinking of doing
don't do it
it's game over if they catch you don't
do it
don't whatever you're thinking of doing
don't look don't do it whatever you is
thinking you do not want to do this you
don't want to do this please you don't
have to do this do not redeem it don't
redeem it oh God
I'm gonna examine this okay love a tour
go through this study go through the
hallway go past go left
into the bedroom past the kitchen and
grab the fuse and then get back easy
peasy I ain't afraid of no ghosts
oh
what are you gonna do huh what happens
if I Look Away what happens what happens
if I Look Away what happens oh
[Music]
that's Mommy
oh
come on
do something
do something my Daria
what are you doing oh my God that's what
I thought that's what I thought you're
pathetic you're pathetic try it
try it yeah I thought so you wimp yeah
oh well you're just too easy
too simple
simple
oh God oh God
Hi listen you suck
and also
I hate you
goodbye
okay there's not more than one
mommy is there
stop
oh God
I don't know why I'm in here why did I
decide to go in here I don't know
probably get more distance that's what I
thought
try me
fool
ing him oh God I see I see oh it's right
there okay all right hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on you being a
little sassy
I don't care for that you're sassy stop
it
I see you out of the corner of my eye
that's what I knew I always bend new I
haven't been in here
don't
no not today not today not today
fuse
done
Jesus Christ
all right so you think you have me
the truth is you don't have anything you
don't have me you don't have hopes you
don't have a heartbeat you don't have an
ass you have nothing
you've got nothing
I oh no way that's not fair okay if I
can
oh stop
stop oh you silly are you so silly there
better not be a third there better not
be a third oh God I'm going I'm going
I'm going
oh no no no no no no no no no
stop there better not be another one
right by me I swear to God okay I was
about to say holy crap oh my God stop
stop oh there's another one
I got this Pro mode yeah oh water no
wait oh God you're blocking the door oh
frick oh frick oh frick
okay nobody move
we're all cool
we're all chill we're all so chill holy
crap we're not chill we're not chill
everyone chill
just chill
no you chill
you all just
chill out
I'm gonna take a little step out of here
and I'm gonna just
chill chill chill chill chill chill
chill
chill everyone chill everyone chill
everyone chill chill
oh
God you are so chill
good
oh God don't do that oh my God okay hold
on ah finally I get to save here
good oh my God oh my God
give me something
don't do it don't do it don't do it I
should be safe I'm gonna uh end this
episode here
this has been very good very productive
I feel very good about this very good
about everything I've done it feels so
good so thank you everybody so much for
watching uh more Resident Evil down in
the comments or the description uh in
the comments or uh the secret code to
the secret thing that you'll definitely
want to know about so go check it out
thank you now as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]